oh oh wichtig war ja ich sterbe gerade
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft exit aus dem
jura wenn man auch zusammen mit lp mit
cathay und wir beenden uns heute wieder
eure twitter franke mal was heißt wie
der letzte folge war nur eine frage
dabei arbeiten die leute fahren direkt
an damit wie man den schnitt hier
steigern
wer ist dein lieblings promi wenn man es
denn so sagen kann lieblings promi oder
so eine art zu wen du so cool findest
das ist eine schwere frage weil ich
meine ganz viele leute oder auch viele
youtuber die scheinen mir wirklich bei
vielen sachen up to date zu sein
das heißt ich habe da wirklich das
gefühl die kennen sich regelrecht aus
mit diversen
ich war da nie so wirklich rein gefuchst
und ich kenne mich dementsprechend da so
wenig aus also generell was promis
angeht was andere youtuber vielleicht
angeht wenn man so manche hätten
natürlich schon aber so im generell ich
weiß nicht weiß was ich meine
ja klar weiß was man ich habe einfach
nicht den überblick und so lieblings
promi keine ahnung also ich weiß gar
nicht ich das beantworten soll
also bei mir ist es jetzt so ich bin
ich weiß nicht worauf man das jetzt
beziehen soll wenn man jetzt sagt ja gut
okay es geht um schauspieler et cetera
dann wenn mein lieblingsschauspieler war
wenn man da an als wäre ich schon an
grenzen bringen erwähnt wer ist mein
lieblingsschauspieler wenn ich geil
findet will smith yahoo es muss irgendwo
drauf der ist auch einfach jetzt auch
einfach so richtig richtig nett also
wenn man in so ein interview sieht und
so der macht auch einfach ein
sympathischen einem spiel einfach der
top boxen so ist würde ich dennoch sagen
also wenn es um das ist immer ich finde
auch so auf den moment fällt einem das
so gar nicht ein das fällt einem so ein
wenn man seinen film gymnastik oder
später auch mit der kann das aber gut
richtig gut der wertvoll für gute filme
gemacht hat man dann so ja und dann aber
jetzt im moment fällt anders richtig
schwer es richtig schwer so ein zu
finden ich bin jetzt echt gespannt das
überhaupt funktioniert weil es könnte
sein dass meine taktik aufgeht gerade
sonst ein lieblings promi finde es gibt
eigentlich promi ist so ein blöder
ausdruck ich meine ich weiß promi sind
menschen so prominente die man halt so
überall kennt die stars ja aber bist du
dann auch einen kombi ja das ist nämlich
auch die sache sind wie rasiert promis
sind youtube war jetzt auch promis weil
ich meine wenn man ja promi so definiert
dass viele menschen die kennen ich meine
wenn man davon ausgeht jeder von uns hat
über eine viertel million abonnenten
mann und sagte das ist ja auch schon
eine anzahl an menschen die offenbar auf
guckt ja und vor allem wenn man das dann
so sieht und dann ist die frage euer
lieblings prom ich mein ich selbst bin
ich selbst und ich möchte mich so so
sein so selbe spiel geringe kontrast
mein lied nein mann ich möchte mich im
spiegel sehen wie ich halt sein möchte
deswegen kann man ja theoretisch sagen
wenn weil wir ja quasi auf mehr oder
weniger promis sind kann man ja seine
lieblings profi bin ich selbst
theoretisch kann man das so sagen weil
man selbst ein profi ist und man selbst
wenn man sagt mein lieblingshobby man
findet sich selbst der quasi mehr oder
weniger man mag sich ja eigentlich als
mensch
und das ist zumindest der jetzige
zustand die man haben sollte so du bist
voll selbst verliebt aber nein es ist
glaube ich einfach so haben wir ich mich
nicht als problem sehen würde dann würde
ich glaube ich irgendeinen schauspieler
nehmen oder irgendeine also jemanden wie
video kontrast die finde ich zb sind
auch richtig riehl die einmal mtv
angefangen und so weiß nicht bei den
beiden dass es bei dir natürlich riehl
angefangen man merkt jetzt schon ich
habe das gefühl mittlerweile sorgen sie
sich immer asozialer aus dem finger wird
sich obwohl natürlich geil ist das
eigentlich wenn kräftig table keine
ahnung also durstigen gesetzt ich hoffe
du hast gesetzt jetzt stelle ich schon
immer bei mir auch leid ich hab alles
dabei ich würde lieber verbringt
so darf ich mal kurz stellt ihr euch an
die wand habe ich meine hände geschosse
fertig und mal kurz auch mal neben die
ich schießen kann man davon ausgehen
dass die schnittstelle mal hier so an
die wand
erstaunt ist überhaupt der mit schwach
weil der mann rief noch am leben
828 schuss fand ich also ich nicht
einfach mal so den kopf mein herz die
sich nur einmal gesunken
so erwarte ich dass man neben dich und
ich habe eine patrone bekommen okay ich
hab zwar eine patrone bekommen aber ach
du scheiße ist das teuer sieht man eben
mich das ist so teuer sind
wir haben ihm am herzen er warte ich
schieße jetzt komplett so an die
vorwürfe die kugel nicht nur in der luft
also die treppe nicht nochmals wenn ich
richtig an dir vorbei schießt so jetzt
ist genau auf dich zu das eigentlich
irgendwo das richtig geil das ist das
ist cool an sich aber wartet bleibt
marketing rapid- feier kurz geschaut
dass wichtig durch tko
je weiter das gericht ich war ja ich
sterbe gerade ich mache nichts mehr die
churer herzlichen ich hatte gerade drei
herzen alter das geht richtig rein wenn
du genug moni hast aber diesen übels
euer alter weil ich sehe gerade man
kriegt das nicht wieder acht schuss
kosten nichts weiß leibolz das heißt
muss mir wenn ich hier also das kochen
sowieso auf love hitler sowie und gold
und ender perlen und alles also wirklich
schneller
die teuer und auch gold was man dann
aber brauch ist jetzt glaube ich
irgendwie eines laien fahren
aber wenn es doch diese ich meine jetzt
weiß ich noch immer diese komischen
gälische slams in dieser normalen slams
verwandelt ja ja dann wäre es halt geil
wenn ja wenn man irgendwo favorit auch
wenn es nur blau ist limestone weil es
kann natürlich gut sein dass die anderen
vielleicht nicht spawnen äußerst geil
ich kann sogar salter drauf verzaubern
wohltäter der täter ja und zwar zu der
frage zurück die seitlich beantwortet
also weiß ich nicht ist eine sehr sehr
blöde frage die frage an sich ist nicht
schwierig zu beantworten ich blöde frage
ist falsche ausdruck
frage finde ich richtig richtig gut was
haltet ihr von dem heutigen
schönheitswahn von fenja miss mini
kuchen
was ist wenn ich ihn habe
was ist mit mini kuchen ist ja auch ihr
name aber aber was können schönheitswahn
weil sie dünn ist oder was nein
schönheitswahn ist ja in unserer
heutigen zeit
ach so die das geschrieben heißt wenn ja
gucken next wie findet ihr den
schönheitswahn von fenja bevor von
nörten die wirklich so ja das ist
nämlich auch wieder so eine sache wo man
rief mich lange darüber diskutieren kann
also damals war es ja so dass das
schönheitsideal war dass menschen so
jetzt hab ich das wenn man inventar
vermischt das nicht so gut dass menschen
etwas dicklicher waren aber das ist
heute auch nie mehr so eng doch also
heutzutage euro wenn du merkst in
amerika sind über 50
weil ich ja meinen das hört sich
vielleicht negativ an wenn man
vielleicht korpulente menschen mit dem
wort qualle in verbindung setzt aber was
ist wenn ich qualle mag ich mag weil es
nicht mag backfisch wieso kriegt diese
drei manchester nicht abgebaut was ich
noch fahren wollte deine leistung ist
voll verzaubert oder eine rüstung ja
auch mit protect schon alle möglichen
das noch nicht dass kein protection auf
der rüstung ja bisschen ich bin echt
gespannt das hat ja echt richtig rein
geknallt bio tabak rastow aber du bist
ja ich liebe dich verzaubert deswegen
weiß nicht ob man das so als voll nehmen
kann so dass ihr die frage jetzt weiß
ich dass ich vieles sei missbrauch
irgendwo eine möglichkeit wie diese
hässlichen blauen slams findet slime
spex etwas kann also ich hätte einfach
mal weiter und zwar
war es ja wirklich damals so dass da wo
ich stell' ich brauche meine ganze
kisten hätten damals was er so dass er
dicklich das schönheitsideal war aber
heutzutage ist es ja so dass die
menschen in der modelbranche also und
verbinden sich jetzt gar nicht als mega
hübsche angesehen werden das verstehe
ich halt gar nicht weil ich finde dieses
dünne ich dich richtig eklig wenn man so
richtig abgemagert ist das ist bei
frauen so eklig aus und das ist doch
nicht mehr der schönheitswahn
doch der schönheitswahn ist das
mittlerweile der schwestern so
abgemagert erstmal jedes jahr alle
möglichen frauen und models die sind ja
viele sind ja magersüchtig ich hatte das
gefühl dass es jetzt wieder wissen ins
gespräch reingekommen ist das wieder die
frau also zumindest in der modelwelt
halt gestellt dass gestattet ist dass
sie auch begründungen zeigt ja ja klar
das ist es ist hoffe ich auch dass das
gestattet wird
aber ich finde mittlerweile als es war
lange zeit so dass man mega dünn sein
musste und so das hat man ja auf die
jüngsten morde chance gesehen und blabla
und das finde ich ist komplett falsch
entwicklung weil sie morgens manchmal so
eklig und das ist einfach nur schlimm
auch für den körper das ist richtig blöd
ich mag sowas garnicht und vor allem das
ist doch kein ideal man sich also wenn
ihr model werden wollte denkt nicht dass
ihre bibel sub nehmen müsst ihr müsst
einfach ein bisschen wirklich aussehen
und dem es spaß dran haben das ist halt
einfach so da wird wieder sowas spaß mit
solltest du halt nicht sein aber
vielleicht ein bisschen alles war
einfach gibt bing ist nicht alles
gesundem maße ich meine hallo hallo ich
weiß gar nicht was machen soll ich finde
hier nix ich weiß nicht wie ich weiß
nicht wie ich slams finden soll
jung ich hab einfach 1000 kisten und
weiß nicht was ich mit den ganzen sachen
machen soll
ich denke die gegend um wunderschöne
abzählen weil ich suche so eine an edith
wollten gibt ist ja gar nicht meiner
version wurde mir gesagt ich mache jetzt
einfach kurz ein kleines arbeiten
also ich halte vom schönheitswahn auch
nicht so viel ich hab das gar nicht so
in erinnerung dass es so dünn war das
hatte ich vor ein paar jahren mal im
kopf aber dachte mittlerweile wäre das
wieder ad acta gelegt kann einfach und
herunter an unserem stand das scheint
genau das scheint einfach es
wahrscheinlich nicht durchgedrungen oder
so ich dachte eigentlich wie gesagt dass
jetzt auch etwas kurviger der frauen im
kommen sind was auch eigentlich ganz
nett ist
ich meine jeder kennt das da braucht man
auch denke ich mal nicht lügen im wenn
keine ahnung in nur zwei identischen
medien vergleichen würdest und eine
mehrheit einfach so das hört sich die
fifa will man das so sagt aber irgendwo
spielt außerdem natürlich schon eine
rolle aber es ist sowieso erstens nicht
alles und zweitens muss es trotz noch in
einem gesunden rahmen sein und der das
schönheitsideal was ich es ist so wie
über gekünstelt eigentlich schon das ist
schon too much das ist nicht mehr das
was schön ist sondern das ist das was
sozusagen als schön interpretieren
vorher noch weiter gedacht und dann
einfach noch sozusagen übertrieben
eigentlich schön ist nicht mehr die
schönheit sondern das was die
gesellschaft daraus macht
ich finde das portal ich bin einfach nur
enttäuscht
ok jetzt ist ein wirklich netter lüge
ich hab' ich hab das portal oder sagen
spielen ich mit mir spielen waren wir
wirklich sonst leim und slava wie lassen
aber ich komme
einmal lava slime halter jobless claims
ist my balls meinst du ja weil sie nicht
ich weiß aber dass ich keine lava finde
der härtesten der wahl für männer keine
lava ich finde keine lava die hier kann
ich nicht aufsammeln irgendwas ist
glaube ich nicht bei den girls einmal
wurde ich heiße lava kein soldat ihr
tötet zwar seinen verpackten slime hier
und schaue was der also drop schach so
das ist magma cube ja wohl vertan hier
aber das ding ist ich brauche echt
irgend etwas handfestes jetzt langsamer
ich brauche wirklich leute bitte
schreibt mir in die kommentare schreiben
bei facebook weiß ich was ich will diese
idee mit der munition das ding ist es
soll sich nicht so schnell verbreiten
das heißt braucht die tipps schnell wenn
wir das schnell durchsetzen kann und
paar weg flexen kann immer noch dicke
hose machen weil das scheint ja echt
richtig geil damage zu machen
es trifft einfach immer egal ob er damit
im flugzeug fliegt für die hinterher und
schießereien also ich brauche mindestens
so geil wäre schon so ein steak slams
länder quad ich weiß dass es hoch
gepokert
16 teams ist nicht wenig von gast so ich
schau mal was ist in der mitte der map
vielleicht einmal darin die gas trainer
fällt in die lava oder slave aber
richtig viele und niveau achso um ein
portal ist das kann ich jetzt sagen
falls du das aufschreiben willst das ist
bei 497 welches ja mein mit meine mitte
porta weiß wo das anderes von links
danke für dich für danke für dich will
sehe ich eine hilfe
danke danke jetzt komme ich zurück statt
rot
aber verlaufen hier jedoch doch gehabt
jetzt komme ich zurück in stadt roth vor
allem sage ich es statt blau
ich bin einfach nur am verzweifeln ich
brauche slams conny glaubt gar nicht wie
sehr ich brauche für eine coole pistole
da halten ja weil das geht ich habe
unterschätzt ich wusste nicht dass nur
für die pistole bräuchten slime aber ich
brauche für vier shows ein slime für
vier schuss das ist so übel
aber ich gebe euch mal in diese zwischen
dimension schaue was ihr da ist doch
soll ich mal wieder noch eine frage eben
frage ja ich bin ja wie gesagt gerade
jetzt in der zwischen dimension ich
hoffe hier einfach gerade das was
verwirrt dich am meisten an der
menschlichen philosophie was für eine
philosophie wahrscheinlich meint bzw
ich glaube dass wir die die normen die
wir mit denen wir in der gesellschaft
zurzeit leben also dass die philosophie
beispielsweise dass jeder mensch
arbeiten muss was alles ich war aber
sonst weiß ich auch nicht menschliche
philosophie
wieso bin ich denn jetzt in dieser
unterwelt gelang menschen helfen soll
lukas für den staat tun soll die natur
instand halten soll so was halt jetzt
eigentlich bin ich eine unterwelt
gelandet auch du kämpfst du das fragt
mich nicht vor allem ich verstehe dass
noch nicht alle sagen mir immer wenn ich
ihn unter weggehe sterbe ich sterbe
nicht fallen einfach runter und dann
laufe ich jetzt hier um die ecke
geschmissen so wichtig anspruchsvolle
fragen also nicht wirklich gedanken zu
machen
richtig kurve gedacht zur hilfe kommt
ihr sowas an was hätte ich nie gedacht
also würden es denn an der menschlichen
philosophie
also ich würde erstmal sagen verwirrend
finde ich daran liegt weil wir haben es
ja mehr oder weniger mitbestimmen mit
der zeit und video und ja auch was sich
verwirrend finde jetzt kommt und zwar
ich finde so verwirrend dass es wird von
dingen ausgang von kleinen teilen der
menschlichen welt sei einfach mal und
zwar bezieht sich das ist nicht okay
atome elektronik denke dass alles schon
ob bewiesen
kann man alles nachweisen aber es gibt
teilweise diverse theorien was ich
richtig komisch finde ist zum beispiel
so diese mehr dimension theorie dass
halt es unendlich viele parallel
universen gibt uns so und allein
ich meine wenn man sich da wissen so
rein denkt dann hast du über 18 minuten
spätestens eine macke
aber ich frage mich dann einfach immer
wie ist jemand einfach so morgens mal
aufgewacht und soja es gibt parallel
universen so dass farben und kopflos ich
finds auch was mich immens aller
menschlichen philosophie verwirrt dass
wir wirklich davon ausgehen dass die
welt durch einen riesigen planeten der
auf und stürzt untergeht das kann
natürlich sein dass er von bliebe ja das
sagt auch alle möglichen leute es
gewesen wäre wurden schon so viele
weltuntergänge hervor gesagt das ist
einfach nur alles schwachsinn weil das
einzige waren unsere welt untergehen
kann es einfach durch die klimaerwärmung
dass die eisschollen die heißen dass
nicht schon dass die lager platten
worauf wir leben
diese tektonischen platten ein wir leben
es gibt ganz viele verschiedene platten
verschieben sich immer mehr wenn ihr
nicht verschieben entstehen zunahme
dieser zeitrahmen die tektonischen
platten wie schon die tektonischen
platten ja nein das anders sehen wie wir
grüßen platten tektonische platten mio
also die tektonischen platten hat
irgendwie anderen begriff vielleicht hat
mit anderen begriffen schuldig
das gefühl ist bei uns anders ich wette
dies wird an ließen aber anschließen die
die platte aber das ist eigentlich
unlogisch ich will die globale erwärmung
ist sogar gut in irgendeinem maße und
zwar weil richtig killer also das ding
ist die nächste eiszeit die wird
natürlich die menschheit nicht aus
worten klar aber die wird natürlich
denke ich mal so die menschheit so um 50
prozent dezimiert ganz bestimmt und es
ist einfach so kanal nur alle paar
millionen jahre kommt aber eine eiszeit
und wenn wir aber weiterhin so machen
mit der globalen erwärmung dann ist das
so dass der planet sich um die 23 grad
so aufgeheizt hat das keine eiszeit mehr
stattfinden kann natürlich ist das auch
kurzsichtig argumentiert weil meine wenn
keine eiszeit stattfinden kann
vielleicht ist das so ein natürlicher
planet habe also den ganzen planeten
betreffender regenerationsprozess oder
so er das einfach mal braucht und wenn
mal ein bisschen runter kommt der plan
des planeten erde planet erde muss
chillen
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen ich habe
auch noch gar nichts davon gehört dass
eine eiszeit wieder kommt leisten bis
100 prozentig sicher die frage ist nur
wann und ob sie kommt je nachdem wie
waren der planet ist und die spätestens
also deswegen freue ich mich auch schon
wenn irgendwann die ganzen wenn wir
irgendwann zum mars fliegen und da sind
schwindel und stationen aufbauen weil
spätestens nach glaube ich die reihe
billion jahren ist die erlösung sofort
weil die sonne dann bestimmt war erwacht
man kann zurecht und hat errechnet dass
anhand der masse von wasserstoff ist
glaube ich enthalten wie viel jahren
also das ist auch im fall der doppelte
zeitraum so lang wieder planet existiert
und ihr müsst bedenken dass die
menschheit lebt ja erst dann plötzlich
falsches sagen 5000 jahre vielleicht
obwohl ja vielleicht sieht man diese
affenmenschen noch mit oder was weiß ich
was oder wie auch immer
aber der planet am maschener so 18
milliarden jahre alt das heißt die
lebzeit des menschen noch mal so ein
wichtiger furz und wenn man sich noch
vorstellen dass die menschheit von den
von der sonne her noch ein paar
milliarden jahre hat es eigentlich ganz
schnell ich hatte mal auf die faule haut
legen unsere folge ist vorbei also was
ich eigentlich denke ist das wenn die
welt wirklich unter geht das
jetzt haben wir diese frage die da war
dass wir über die philosophie des
menschen diskutieren sollen einfach auf
die es ja theologie rübergebracht also
auf das den untergang der welt das
armageddon die apokalypse
nein das ist er theologie psychologie
ist religiös gesehen das leben nach dem
tod und die situation im sterben also
wie wir sterben
willst du nicht oder wie viel ihr
apokalypse anderes wort für agenda
das ist ein viel viel kompliziertes
thema worüber man 1000 jahre diskutieren
könnte dann sind wir schon alle tot
es wird auf jeden fall ich die die welt
wird nicht untergehen in der zeit wo wir
noch leben
damit müssen die späteren generationen
clark auf eure kinder werden noch spaß
haben ja auch ihr werdet noch spaß damit
der welt von daher würde ich sagen wir
werden aber diese folge wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass eine positive
bewertung der und sonst würde ich sagen
wir uns in der nächsten folge der
einfach gut und bei lotto